so I've got a bit of a confession to
make this morning I was watching my
videos with my media coach Janey when
going over the most recent videos and I
found that I wasn't quite me yet in the
videos not like I used to be in my old
videos I had a lot more passions a lot
more yelling you know I'd be screaming
at the camera and in the more recent
ones that that hasn't been there and I
was trying to figure out how to get back
to it and what I realized was in the
past four weeks I've I've had a camera
person helping me the first two weeks
were these two people I tried out the
past two weeks have been Jason who's an
amazing guy who's behind the camera
right now and I found myself being a
little more nervous a little a little
safer a little more guarded I found that
I was talking faster on my videos then I
was in the old ones and my old process
used to be I would look at whatever I
was going to talk about whatever
question I had and I would you know pace
around my my my place for a couple
minutes think of what I wanted to say
then get right in the camera and start
saying it and I didn't care if I was
yelling or screaming or you know whoever
was in the office and and now I find you
know we've got to set up the shots and
and there's somebody who's you know
watch everything that I'm saying and as
a result again I feel a little guarded
and I'm not as passionate as I used to
be and I feel like it's because I'm a
little bit nervous and I think you know
hopefully you can relate to this whether
you're stretching your comfort zone and
doing new things to help your business
grow and you get a little bit nervous
about it and the easy thing for me to do
would be to say well this is scary this
is new this is boundary-pushing so I'm
going to go back to his room before
because that's safe and that that worked
but that's not in the best interest of
my business that's on the best interest
of this channel that's not of the
benches of you guys because the
production quality has gone way up and
we get videos done so much faster we can
have some fun with the b-roll and the
quality is way better than I was doing
it myself and the key is then for me to
get better to me to get more comfortable
for me too
stretch my comfort zone and in that
stretch it is by definition
uncomfortable and a little bit scary and
it just requires breaking through your
nervousness and conquering your
nervousness it's okay to be nervous you
know when you're trying new stuff but
it's not being a slave to those nerves
and not holding back on what you want to
do because you're scared or nervous and
so that's just a quick confession today
after I was looking through some of my
older videos and I'm looking forward to
getting back to tour was and having the
same passion enthusiasm that I had I
think I'm close I think it's pretty good
I'm not beating myself down too hard
what I wanted to get next level and so I
know we're on our way and my thought or
my question I guess for you guys is I
want to know what you're scared of or
what you're nervous about and what
change you're trying to make in your
business that you are afraid to tackle
and share that in the comments below and
hopefully through sharing and making a
public that releases you a little bit of
those nerves in that fear and helps you
be more of who you are and take that
risk to take your business to the next
level where you want it to be so thank
you guys for watching I look forward
your comments continue to believe and
I'll see you soon